oui mais voilà dans la nuit d'hier
sergueï lavrov vérifier qu'elle est
imprimée aux canards et parable mètres
précise intel dans les serres a précisé
vladimir poutine a soulevé hier non à
cacher la drogue et alcool d'eurosport
et compromissions la polio d'intéressant
c'est la réplique à marion rialland
venezuela m ou vieira constitutionnel et
à l'épaule lors des soldes douzy
venezuela et nt1 notamment célébré noël
c'est nbc universal les relations
diplomatiques
yacine d'où la volonté la révolution
bolivarienne
dans des lettres aux la sauce
bilatérales et internationales
cajamarca commandant hugo chavez camilo
horizon national
tout d'abord je voudrais remercier la
délégation russe d'être venu au
venezuela
je voudrais souligner que cette année en
fait le 75e anniversaire de
l'établissement des relations
bilatérales entre la russie et le
venezuela
et c'est relations ont été renforcées
par monsieur de chaves cette politique
qui a été menée par monsieur chavez elle
a soutenu par notre président nicholas
maduro afin de travailler dans le cadre
du dialogue bilatéral en respectant
le second est doté de deux pistes de
coopération mais sur la preuve est en
visite dans plusieurs pays de l'amérique
latine et des caraïbes dans le cadre du
dialogue d'aujourd'hui nous avons
examiné en détail toutes les questions
qui sont à l'ordre du jour 1 je voudrais
souligner que monsieur la brouette un
vrai diplomate qui au cours de sa
carrière à prouver qu'il est militant
pour le développement pacifique des pays
et c'est à la différence des diplomates
occidentaux qui optent dont le chantage
la coopération et
comment il y aura là
[Musique]
comme j'ai déjà dit cette année nous
allons fêter le 75e anniversaire de
l'établissement des relations
diplomatiques entre la fédération de
russie et le venezuela
et cette année nous allons tenir une
réunion de la commission
intergouvernementale pour parler de
l'approfondissement de notre coopération
dans le domaine politique et économique
nous allons toujours respecter la charte
des nations unies afin de lutter contre
les mesures unilatérales comme le
président m'a nouveau a déjà souligné le
développement du venezuela de tendre de
la paix de la coopération mutuelle et
aujourd'hui nous avons tenu cette
négociation pour montrer que venezuela
se prononce pour la démocratie
et comme le président nicholas maduro a
dit aujourd'hui pour le venezuela
il n'y a pas de possibilité de accepter
la pression entre la liste
il a dit que le venezuela allait suivre
la voie de la démocratie
monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui nous demandons d'être ici au
venezuela comme chez vous comme l'a dit
madame la vice présidente que je salue
voilà les relations sont très bonne
entre nous mesdames messieurs je tiens à
souligner qu effectivement je me sens
ici comme chez moi et je remercie la
partie vénézuélienne pour cet accueil si
chaleureux
donc nous avons une digue ne visitent
effectivement très dense avec de longues
discussions approfondies temps avec le
président m'a d'euros qu'avait que le
ministre affaires étrangères madame la
vice présidente et les différents
ministres chargés des questions
économiques et nous avons accordé une
grande attention aux questions concrètes
qui concerne la suite de nos relations
bilatérales et dans ce contexte la
tension majeure était accordée aux
accords qui ont été conclus entre nos
deux présidents lors de notre entrevue à
moscou en septembre dernier
et nous avons souligné l'importance de
préserver la souveraineté le pays et
nous avons manifesté notre solidarité
envers le venezuela notamment dans ce
contexte de pressions illégal exercées
par les etats-unis et leurs sbires et
bien entendu ces sanctions et ses
chantages sont des procédures tout à
fait illégal et encore une fois nous
appelons à nous en tenir à la charte de
l'onu et de respecter la souveraineté du
pays
dans toutes ses dimensions et le fait
que nos deux pays soit uni dans cette
défense à s'en tenir à défendre le
statut de l'onu et à agir dans ce
contexte est pour nous un très bon signe
et nous allons poursuivre la prendre
l'approfondissement de nos relations au
niveau international et nous cherchons
les moyens de renforcer notre
coopération au niveau économique
culturel politique face aux pressions
qui sont exercées de l'extérieur
et notamment nous voyons des
possibilités de coopération renforcée
dans le domaine de l'énergie de
l'agriculture de la production
industrielle des ressources des nerthe
d'énergies naturelles et notamment aussi
dans le domaine de la coopération
militaire nous allons poursuivre nos
échanges et de façon à ce que nos amis
puissent se défendre contre toutes les
agressions extérieures qui peuvent se
manifester et les aspects pratiques de
cette coopération seront traités en
détail au mois de mai lors de la
prochaine réunion
la prochaine session de la commission de
coopération entre nos deux pays et nous
avons encore une fois manifester notre
soutien total au président maduro dans
sa volonté d'instaurer un dialogue
national pour que toutes les parties
puissent s'entretenir et 2 et concertée
se concerter les unes avec les autres
et cette politique tout à fait cohérente
se voit manifesté dans la population
c'est ce que nous avons constaté
aujourd'hui lors de la table ronde qui a
été organisée cette table ronde de
dialogue national où étaient représentés
tant le gouvernement que des partis de
l'opposition
et encore une fois ça a été confirmée
aujourd'hui par le président m'a d'euros
c'est à dire que cette plate forme de
dialogue est ouverte à tous ceux qui
sont prêts à discuter avec les autorités
sur l'avenir du pays et cela nous sommes
tout à fait positif et à long terme
notamment dans le cadre de l'initiative
des autorités vénézuéliennes de faire
appel à des observateurs étrangers pour
suivre un petit peu ce processus
politique
et cela confirme encore une fois que la
volonté de nos amis venus et liens de
défendre des processus et des principes
démocratiques de dialogue et de
d'instauration poursuite de cette
véritable démocratie
seul le peuple vénézuélien peut décider
de l'avenir de son pays et la russie
fera tout son possible pour manifester
son soutien notamment dans le cadre du
partenariat stratégique
et justement au mois de mars nous
fêterons les 75 ans de l'établissement
de relations diplomatiques et pour
conclure je tiens à rappeler que nous
invitons chaleureusement le président
maduro à se rendre à moscou pour le 9
mai
2020 lorsque nous fêterons les 75 ans de
la victoire sur le nazisme à la fin de
la deuxième guerre mondiale
encore une fois merci pour votre
merveilleuse hospitalité